Well, let's see.
The first thing I want to figure
out is how many cups of juice
my guests are going to drink.
And since I have 26 guests and
they're each going to drink 5 cups,
they're going to drink
26 x 5 cups of juice.
And that's equal to 130 cups.
But I want to know how
many liters to buy.
So first I'm going to
convert to gallons so
that I can then convert
from gallons to liters.
So, I'm going to multiply by
1 gal divided by 16 cups,
which lets me simplify cups.
And then multiply by my gallon to liter
conversion of 3.785 liters per gallon.
Gallon simplifies, and
I'm left with liters.
When I carry out this multiplication,
I find that I need 30.75 liters,
which would actually mean I
should buy 31 one-liter bottles.
So if you put 31 that was okay, too.